hello everybody so I just met with
President Trump and he is authorized and
will be signing a new executive order
giving the Treasury Department in
consultation with himself and secretary
Pompeo very significant new sanctions
authorities that can be targeted at any
person associated with the government of
Turkey any portion of the government
this will be both primary sanctions and
secondary sanctions that will be
applicable the president is concerned
about the ongoing military offensive and
potential targeting of civilians
civilian infrastructure ethnic or
religious minorities and also the
president wants to make very clear it is
imperative that turkey not allow even a
single Isis fighter to escape again I
want to emphasize at this point we are
not activating the sanctions but as the
president has said he will provide very
significant authorities based upon the
continuing efforts so he will be signing
this they will be active we will be
working in consultation with the
Department of Defense and Department of
State to monitoring this very quickly we
are putting financial institutions on
notice that they should be careful and
that there could be sanctions again
there are no sanctions at this time but
this will be the broadest executive
authorities delegated to us
and can you tell us when would you put
it through sanctions and what would it
take actually actually okay well on no I
don't think he thinks his actions are
what led to this it is a complicated
situation is a situation that we're all
concerned about and the humanitarian
situation and there are very clear
discussions that will be going on
between the Department of Defense and
the State Department I just got off the
phone with the finance minister and we
will be communicating specifics that
we're not going to tell I want to make
sure everybody knew in advance I wasn't
talking about China because I didn't
when I think I was calling his specific
China meeting we have had productive two
days of discussions ambassador light
Hauser and myself with the Vice Premier
and others we will be meeting with the
president shortly we will be updating
the president on those he'll then be
meeting with the vice premier I wouldn't
be surprised if like usual he decides to
invite a few of you in but I'm not going
to make any other comments in advance of
us meeting with the president the stock
market is very optimistic about what it
sees over at the US two years TRS office
are they right to be optimistic
stock markets always right again I'm not
I'm not going to make any more comments
I've said we've had productive two days
of discussions we'll be making more
announcements after we meet with the
president
yes so far Turkey has not been dissuaded
by anything this administration has done
or the president has said what makes you
confident that the announcement you just
made is going to change turkeys why I
don't I don't agree with your premise
I'm not going to comment on specific
confidential discussions that have been
going on on different levels so I don't
think that's a good premise but again
these are very powerful sanctions we
hope we don't have to use them but we
can shut down the Turkish economy if we
need to help these US allies who say
they've been abandoned again it's a
complicated military situation that is
ongoing there are discussions I think
the president has had very specific
discussions as I said the Department of
Defense we have expectations this is a
way of making sure that we protect the
manatorian issues and the other people
on the ground I'm not aware of anything
that's changed but again I'm not
confirming that I just haven't heard
anything one way or another are you
having with lawmakers like Lindsey
Graham senator Van Hollen who has been
really very critical of the pullout of
US troops from Syria Secretary of Pompeo
has been speaking to them daily I've
been speaking to the secretary multiple
times a day I think the message to
Congress is I know that people were
contemplating sanctions were on top of
sanctions the president will use them
when necessary thank you everybody